I'm sure you've all gotten into the
console war at some point ps4 and xbox
one always fighting for first place but
which brand do all the hip teens think
is cooler I'm Tony in this game spot
news update has the answer a study
commissioned by Google asked a simple
question which brands are the coolest
both xbox and playstation were found on
the list and children from age 13 to 17
aka teens ranked xbox higher than
PlayStation Xbox took fourth place
overall behind YouTube and first Netflix
and second and Google itself in third
playstation took seventh place however
that was flipped around when Millennials
those aged 18 to 25 voted themselves
placing PlayStation ahead of xbox if you
want to stay in the know on these
all-important console wars surveys be
sure to subscribe the same study also
mentioned game series most popular among
the teen demographic these include
Pokemon minecraft grand theft auto and
The Legend of Zelda speaking of which
why not check out our awesome breadth of
the wild april fools video on how to
pilot a guardian
[Music]